how you reject Nation
we are here to do the Barbie main
trailer reaction be a good doll and uh
leave a like on this video if you're
excited for the Barbie movie also John
do you know how you're always like
jealous of Paul from heavy spoilers
Channel you're like Greg you talk with
him so much uh man what's going on in
your conversations and I'm like no John
leave me alone it's my life shut up go
away well get ready to be more jealous
John cause heavy spoilers and I we have
started up a podcast that is debuting on
his channel real spoilers today at
another one o'clock or two o'clock P.M
Pacific Standard time I don't know
exactly know what time it is his choice
he's in control of our relationship
subscribe to his channel that's why he's
doing this and so I can send more
subscribers his way
what a
hey Barbie
can I come to your house tonight wow I
don't have anything they planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and planned choreography in a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
[Music]
diamonds under my eyes oh how fun it is
the best day ever and so is yesterday
and so is tomorrow and every day for now
[Music]
what
existence
[Laughter]
cold shower falling off my roof and my
heels
are on the ground
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my how beautiful this looks you have
to go to the real world
you can go back to your regular life or
you can know the truth about the
universe
the first one the high heel you have to
want to know okay do it again
that's a freaking stock
[Music]
I'm coming with you okay
wow
I love the look of the song it's the
real world Barb is afraid what's going
on why are these men looking at me yeah
they're also staring at me
[Music]
this movie is not for you
that's impossible if this got out this
could be an extremely weird things for
our world this is what
catastrophic we haven't played with
Barbie since we were like five years old
oh my who's this for it's even more Lego
than Lego he's back in a box
nobody else
I only have one ending get that Barbie
Mattel ideas live forever
[Music]
just one appendectomy but I'm a man but
not a doctor can I talk to a doctor you
are talking to a doctor I need a clicky
pen No a sharp thing no there he is
Doctor somebody gets security ugh
Holy balls all right well once again
yeah I think this movie does look at
absolutely beautiful it is a gorgeous
looking film and we actually got a very
clear-cut sense of the plot this time as
opposed to the teaser trailers the
teacher trailers I still might have
actually liked a tad bit more just
because there was such a a Charming
Oddity that still carries over to here
with the part of the movie that I'm a
bit concerned about how it might
ultimately play out is actually when
they leave Barbie land I I'm very I was
very much drawn to everything within
Barbie land when they get to the real
world that's when it starts to look a
little bit like
you know I feel like I've seen this kind
of movie before that version of it of
stepping into the real world it's like
kind of reminds me of like a lot of
Christmas movies uh you know some people
a lot of people are liking this to
things like elf and there's like Santa
movies like that it's like they were
like is that really Santa Claus out here
I still have a lot of faith in the
filmmakers and that was the only time in
all of the mark anymore I was like I
wonder how this part of it is actually
going to go down and here's the other
part of my brain that is also clicking
off is I feel like there's a lot of this
movie that's very hard to communicate of
what they're going for within a trailer
span that's why they probably needed two
teaser trailers and then a full main
trailer so that way they can get
audiences acquainted with this world and
also whatever weird tone this is because
there is like two tones I'm seeing here
the big Studio film and then also that
Greta gerwick independent kind of movie
as well I mean this even ends off on
what I I imagine is the theme of this
movie because there's so much of these
existentialism qualities to what
Barbie's journey is about questioning
her reality and questioning the world
and wanting to learn more uh where it
says there's something at the end about
humans have a shorter lifespan but ideas
live forever I don't really know how
that's going to play into the Barbie
character development I get that for the
concept of what Barbie is and what
Barbie represents I mean do you have any
thoughts on that I I'm curious I mean
because certainly it seems like Barbie
is going through as you point out like
an existential crisis she's trying to
find the nature of her reality her place
in the world and then as they go to you
know the the real world it seems as
though she is certainly being stuffed
back into very traditional gender role
boxes and uh Society imposes so I wonder
if it's more just about breaking free
and sort of following your own instincts
following your own voice things like
that and carving your own path because
yeah it's like the idea of the Barbie is
that she has been so many things the
idea has been redefined so many times so
maybe that's going to be the sort of
thematic thrust I mean I am curious
about how the Ultimate Experience of the
movie will pan out because the teaser
trailers communicated a certain greater
sense of like surreality to the
proceedings whereas you know this takes
place obviously in a surreal world in
Barbie World Barbie land whatever you
call it
um and then them you know sort of
transitioning out of there into the real
world certainly looks like it'll take us
through a bunch of stylized environments
and things like that but it makes me
wonder how much of that surreal nature
is actually going to flavor the movie
itself is it going to bend your mind a
little bit at all in a fun way
um but yeah how much of that because you
start with that teaser with the 2001 and
everything and it certainly gives you
this CS sort of uh more meta anarchic
sort of quality than than these
subsequent trailers have not that that's
a bad thing well I imagine maybe the
first half is a little more quirky and
the second half is when they get a lot
more emotional sure yeah you know when
they're actually stepped into the the
real world circumstances as I I think
the part that's been most appealing
about this for a lot of people has been
the strangeness behind this film but
even for them to lead with the marketing
of saying for both camps this movie is
not for you oh geez sucks such an odd
Choice I'm not saying they don't know
how I just imagine it's a bit of a
challenge to truly to convey when the
whole package is really gonna feel like
I mean I like those kind of movies as
well you know I think one of the first
ones I ever saw was the Johnny Depp
brand new film Don Juan DeMarco of is he
really Don Juan DeMarco like all the all
the humans interacting with Johnny WC
really don't want and that's what
they're doing here with Barbie and Ken I
don't know how much that's gonna be part
of it because it seems like they're
immediately sold that that is Barbie
sure yeah yeah at least maybe the adults
are I don't know about the kids maybe
but I still really like it a lot it
still looks like a lot of fun yeah and
oh yeah it still looks like it has tons
of imagination and and I mean
craftsmanship alone on display lots of
enthusiastic Talent yeah yeah I just
feel like we've been doing nothing but
heat tons of praise for this we gotta
you know balance the scales a tad bit
here yeah
um yeah kind of get some grapes gotta
get some nits
um but I think Margot Robbie's still
gonna absolutely kill it I feel like
Ryan Gosling is still gonna absolutely
kill he still looks absolutely hilarious
uh Will Ferrell looks like he's doing
Will Ferrell
Lord Business is back it's crazy to me
because I've seen Will Ferrell really uh
you know stretch his legs before and for
this it's like yeah looks like what
Will Ferrell does I hope they're hiding
some kind of other layer or surprise
with his character than just just that
yeah but all right guys what did you
think about this trailer leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like keep it looking for that
podcast last but not least I sent us for
the patron of the day shout out Ricardo
Martinez Ricardo looking through some of
the messages that uh we exchanged with
each other not long ago on our patreon
page and I don't know did you know this
he was actually a war vet I did not know
that that is nice that's incredible I
mean that's Iraqi War veteran and it was
it's kind of surprising to me whenever
someone uh of who's contributed to this
country and has been willing to risk
their life yeah to do something that I
cannot imagine myself actually going
through I just don't see it in I don't
have that I don't have the kind of
character and strength that you are able
to go through with them there's so many
other vets out there as well of who've
had to make that courageous decision and
on top of that the
the hardship that comes following you
know posts coming back from a war if you
happen to survive and there's so many
vets out there and we've met other vets
who are a part of the reject Nation as
well as yourself and whenever I meet
someone like that I'm like man you're
the you're the ones we really should be
admiring shouts out to all the Vets as
well man
um yeah Ricardo thank you so much man
even I you've been nothing but generous
and kind with us this whole time and
then learning that I was like oh damn oh
man I didn't realize I mean we meet a
lot of people especially uh who are part
of our patreon and also you know just
subscribers as well who have served in
you know like several branches of the
military
but very few have actually you know
fought overseas so to me I'm like wow
that is that is very
I can't imagine I just can't imagine
what you've had to deal with especially
coming back so shouts out to you and
shouts out to all the Vets who have been
a part of rejection and if you're not
part of reject Nation shouts out to all
the vets in general
big respect cannot do what you guys do
alrighty guys well thank you Ricardo
thank you guys for being here see y'all
soon
[Music]